في أعقاب مذبحة مسجد
في مدينة بامباري بجمهورية أفريقيا الوسطى ، شوهدت
12 جثة على الأقل على
الأرض سيدة وطفل من بين القتلى
عشرات المدنيين الذين
احتموا بمسجد التقوى في ذلك اليوم.
يقول شهود عيان إن المرتزقة
الروس والقوات الحكومية جاءوا للبحث عن مقاتلين من المتمردين داخل المسجد ، لكن بدلاً من العثور على ملاذ ، أخبر CNN أنهم أصبحوا أهدافًا وطلب منا الروس إخراج
النساء والأطفال
من المسجد ، وخرج ستة
منا بأيدينا.
قاموا بتفتيشنا ووجدوا شيئًا
لم نقطعه حتى خمسة أمتار عندما
بدأوا في إطلاق النار علينا ،
وتوفي أربعة أشخاص ، قفز أحدهم إلى الحائط
وأصيبت في قدمي اليمنى في
نفس اليوم ، أخبرت جبريلا CNN أن
ابنها البالغ من العمر 15 عامًا قُتل على
يد الروس  أطلقت النار من طائرة هليكوبتر
عندما خرج زوجها ليجدها
، وقد تم إطلاق النار عليه أيضًا
، ودُفن زوجي مع ابني
البالغ من العمر 15 عامًا
عندما انتهى الدفن ، لم نتمكن من ذلك
حتى  قل كلمة كنت أبكي ،
جاء
أطفالي بجواري وهم ينوحون أن الروس هم من قتلوا زوجي وتركوني مع أطفال في ألم وجد تقرير سري للأمم المتحدة أن الانتهاكات قد ارتكبت على كلا الجانبين في بامباري
لكن الروس ربما يكونون قد ارتكبوا
جرائم حرب
ولا يبدو أنها حادثة منعزلة
على مدى عدة أشهر حصلت CNN ومجموعة التحقيق
المستقلة
القرن
على شهادات ووثائق تشير إلى
تورط متعاقدين روسيين تم نشرهم
لتدريب الجيش الأفريقي المركزي
في مجموعة واسعة من الفظائع
أثناء
القتال بين الحكومة والمتمردين.
القوات ،
بما في ذلك عمليات إطلاق النار الجماعية والتعذيب
وحرق القرى ،
تشارك سوركا مكليود في مجموعة عمل الأمم المتحدة
المعنية بالمرتزقة
في مسيرة أرسلت تفاصيل الانتهاكات المزعومة
إلى حكومتي جمهورية إفريقيا الوسطى والروسية والانتهاكات
الجسيمة لحقوق الإنسان ، بما في ذلك عمليات
الإعدام بإجراءات موجزة والقتل المستهدف
والتعذيب والاختفاء القسري والقتل.
وانتهاكات أخرى أعني أننا نتحدث
حول جرائم الحرب هنا من المحتمل ألا نكون
نعم نحن نشهد
بعضًا من أخطر انتهاكات حقوق
الإنسان وانتهاكات القانون الإنساني
ونراها على نطاق واسع على نطاق
واسع ولكن
الناس على الأرض مرعوبون تمامًا
إنه تناقض صارخ مع القصة التي
تخبرنا بها روسيا
في هذا الفيلم السائح الأخير الذي تم
تمويله من قبل شركة مرتبطة
بالمرتزقة
الروس ، وقد تم الإشادة بهم
كمدافعين بطوليين قاموا بتحرير
وسط إفريقيا
في الواقع.
لطالما كانت مثيرة للجدل على
الرغم من أنها تضخمت من 170
مدربًا متعاقدًا في عام 2017
إلى حوالي 2300 الآن وفقًا لوثيقة الأمم المتحدة
التي تم الحصول عليها بحلول القرن
مع أكثر من 30 قاعدة منتشرة في
جميع أنحاء البلاد ، حيث
أظهر مدرس يبلغ من العمر 39 عامًا
ندوبًا
من جروحه.  يقول إن
المرتزقة
الروس أوقعونا في بؤرة استيطانية خارج بامباري
أخذونا إلى القاعدة الروسية
وربطونا بحبل ونجمة  لتعذيبنا ،
لقد استخدموا حربة لإصابة
قدمي اليسرى بعمق ، ويقول إن
أفعالهم كانت شريرة وبربرية ،
نحن نرى نمطًا
من السلوك من قبل هؤلاء المتعاقدين الروس الخاصين ،
وقد حدث هذا في بلدان أخرى
رأيناه على سبيل المثال
فيما يتعلق  إلى ليبيا حيث تورط متعاقدون روسيون من
القطاع الخاص
في مجموعة متنوعة من انتهاكات حقوق
الإنسان في مجموعة متنوعة من
انتهاكات القانون الإنساني الدولي ،
لكن بالنسبة لضحايا هذه الجرائم المزعومة ،
هناك
أمل ضئيل في تحقيق العدالة ، حيث يعتبر
المتعاقدون
العسكريون الخاصون غير قانونيين من الناحية الفنية في روسيا ولذا لا تفعلوا ذلك
.  يوجد رسميًا
ويعيش العديد من السكان المحليين في خوف من
تداعيات
قوة غامضة وغير خاضعة للمساءلة
كلاريسا وارد سي إن إن.